[Applause]
ladies I got to live with it everyday
thank you I know what you're really
happy coz you're not in the fire fire
out here you know what Brian Williams
said this year that it's so true if this
PG&E that's our gas and electric company
turned off power for a million people
that happened in New York be national
news all the time right this you know
what's going on in here at the Santa Ana
winds you know this they picked up so
the Pacific Gas and Electric shut off
the electricity to a million people in
case a spark from one of their wires
would start a wildfire
how's that for logic everybody stay
inside and like dozens of candles in
every room because we don't want to
start a fire
in other news the president United
States is going to be impeached
because he treats subpoenas like parking
tickets he is gone full stone wall on
this Ukrainian thing refuses to turn
over any documents ordering witnesses
not to show up to testify you know as
innocent people do he's pulling that old
trick that the guilty always do ignoring
the crime and acting outraged about the
investigation guys know this one you
know honey it's not about the dick pics
I sent to your sister the fact that you
were snooping in my phone this is the
great irony of the Trump presidency
foreign criminals that was what he got
elected on they have to be kept out of
this country unless they're here to
steal our elections then it's okay all
right
please apparently that was not a joke
apparently that was a think piece and
does not deserve applause anyway but the
guy who is of course his errand boy Rudy
Giuliani now trying to link the Biden's
to Romania first it was Ukraine randon
it was China
now it's Ukraine now it's Romania he's
Dora the conspiracy Explorer he's all
over the world hunting for this [ __ ] and
that is the story that will not go away
I know Trump wanted to but it will not
the Trump was using Giuliani to
investigate Joe Biden and by the way
what a perfect story for Halloween
season a pumpkin using a vampire
to attack a mummy it's a perfect story
and we found I can't make this up we
found out they'd leave vampire has an
assistant whose name is literally Igor
did you see the story on the news
Igor Froman and Lev harness these are
two of Rudy's associates ukrainian-born
who are helping him to dig up dirt on
Joe Budden he had lunch with them
yesterday and then hours later they got
arrested trying to skip the country oh
yeah there they are
seems like only yesterday they were
chasing Macaulay Culkin around his house
[Applause]
well that's not even the worst of the
week today today Trump threatened
sanctions on Turkey and to destroy their
economy for invading Syria and
slaughtering the Kurds something he gave
them the green light to do four days ago
but we can't have a female president
because they're impulsive there's only
four days ago the Trump was like [ __ ]
the Kurds they didn't help us in World
War two
he said that they didn't help us and
were so wait that we punish anyone who
didn't help us in World War two because
you know didn't really help us in World
War two Germany
and I haven't even gotten to the rally
did you see that that he had less than
he was in Minnesota okay and what
longest one ever went on for an hour and
40 minutes it went so late his orange
glow went into night mode and he kept
doing that nasal sniffing thing that he
does that one is not his fault he
suffers some trees no allergies Donald
Trump at a rally he called us political
opponents very sick deranged people who
want to get this erase your future he
called elan o Mara America hating
socialist he said Pelosi was either
really stupid or she's lost it and then
he got to the point of his speech you
can't elect Democrats there there two
devices that one actually thought was a
joke and he also badmouth jay-z
and jay-z said today you know I got 99
problems and a whiny little [ __ ] is one
he also said this he said in this rally
less than he said Biden was only a good
vice president because he understood how
to kiss Barack Obama's ass and a Mike
Pence said good one boss
oh and this is my favorite sorry the
week Pence's wife Karen pence was
talking at a women for Trump rally and
she said the words if you support
president Trump don't be afraid to get
down on your knees
just push Hannity out of the way
you